demi lovato gets candid about her
current friendships lack thereof with
Selena Gomez the Jonas Brothers and her
ex Wilmer Valderrama nearly two years
after being hospitalized for an overdose
Demi has a new manager new music and a
new life motto now in a new interview
with Harper's Bazaar the 27 year old
reveals she left a lot of her past in
the past specifically she says she's no
longer in contact with Nick Kevin and
Joe Jonas of course the Jonas Brothers
have played a pretty big part in her
career and personal life over the years
they go way back to Disney's Camp Rock
Demi is one of my closest friends in the
world and you know I'm here for her
Demi even dated Joe Jonas briefly back
in 2010 then there's yeah in her new I
love me music video fans were quick to
point out that she makes a few Joe Broz
references
that's Demi walking past what looks like
her and Nick from their camp Rock days
then she strolls right on by three
grown-up Nick Kevin and Joe look-alikes
and Demi also addresses her on-again
off-again friendship with Selena Gomez
Demi says right now it's off again
back in January Selena shared a snapshot
of Demi's Grammy performance on her
instace Tori writing I wish there were
words to describe how beautiful
inspirational and deserved this moment
was Demi I'm so happy for you
thank you for your courage and bravery
thank you
yeah well Demi never responded to the
heartfelt message and now she calls
Harper's bizarre quote when you grow up
with somebody you're always going to
have love for them but I'm not friends
with her so it felt dot dot dot yeah dot
dot dot she stopped herself
course-corrected and
then told the bag quote I will always
have love for her and I wish everybody
nothing but the best
all right now I really want to know what
she was gonna say there anybody else
yeah me also revealed that she and her
ex Wilmer Valderrama aren't in contact
anymore either
honestly I only wish nothing but the
most incredible things for the two dated
from 2010 to 2016 and remain close over
the years we've been in each other's
lives were very entire journey you know
so so to syria bowl by such a
multi-faceted artist i'm very proud of
her he even visited Demi in the hospital
after her overdose she's a hero man
she's a retort to urine two young men
and women out there I think that she's
she's you know she's literally the image
of a recovery and and getting their life
together Wilmer got engaged to model
Amanda Pacheco in January and Demi
seemed to reference that in her music
video too right there now she tells the
mad quote I'm really happy for him and I
wish him nothing but the best
but we're not in each other's lives
haven't spoken in a long time and she
says she needed the distance to learn to
be okay on her own when you get into a
relationship with somebody at that young
of an age and then you spend six years
with somebody you don't really get to
learn about yourself okay so let's recap
he's not friends with Wilmer or the Joe
Broz or Selena anymore but she is still
pals with another former Disney alum
Miley Cyrus the two recently rekindled
their friendship on insta live while
talking about the corona virus pandemic
we cannot talk forever and simple people
go down and like I know that you're the
person I want to reach out to I said
like in dark times it's really important
to reach towards those that are
eliminated and I would think that you're
such a light and that it's just even if
it took this crisis to get us connected
again without just like we run into each
other at the studio or like some [ __ ]
that actually connected and really
talking there's like so few of us that
we just need to like never let this
break again for sure
[Music]